après une légère accalmie à l'automne
l'amérique latine a connu une
accélération des contaminations et
d'essai en décembre le nombre de morts
quotidiens s'est stabilisé depuis le 20
janvier au dessus de 3000 par jour en
moyenne soit deux fois plus que
mi-novembre
le brésil est le deuxième pays le plus
endeuillé dans le monde après les états
unis
beaucoup de choses doivent encore se
produire beaucoup de gens doivent encore
être vaccinés beaucoup de doses de
vaccin doivent encore arriver
nous avons besoin que le gouvernement
soit très efficace pour que cela
fonctionne vraiment nous devons prendre
le vaccin nous devons le prendre pour
nous sortir de ce fléau le brésil et le
mexique qu'on sente plus de la moitié
des décès du continent le vaccin rue
spoutnik v a par ailleurs été approuvé
par le gouvernement mexicain pour une
utilisation d'urgence dans le pays
la commission fédérale pour la
protection contre les risques sanitaires
vient d'octroyer l'autorisation
d'urgence au vaccin spoutnik vais créer
pour le centre d'épidémiologie et de
microbiologie de gamme à la ja en russie
il existe donc la possibilité de
l'emporter et de l'utiliser spoutnik
vais également le choix de la bolivie
la campagne de vaccination a été lancée
après avoir reçu vingt mille doses une
infirmière a été la première à recevoir
le vaccin
aujourd'hui on est en plein
développement du virus mais aujourd'hui
nous espérons quelque chose avec ce
vaccin
nous allons protéger près de 20000
personnes aidées par les premiers
vaccins et nous saluons les efforts de
notre président luis arce etc attaque
aura beaucoup d'attentes et d'espoirs
après l'europe le mois dernier
l'amérique latine et le second continent
à atteindre le seuil de six cent mille
décès du co vide 19